how's it going squad fam today I wanted
to flex on you fam because I have the
new honor 7x I know you're jealous I'm a
huge Android fanboy I had the previous
version of this and I'm super happy with
this thing
so obviously I'm gonna show it up it's
got a full view feature which makes the
screen even bigger when you're playing
games
it feels amazing in your hand seriously
I could touch this thing all day the
screen is amazing the color is amazing
I've been playing in a couple games on
it and I never get like it's super
smooth it's the perfect phone for gaming
and I couldn't be happier with it
honestly it's a perfect phone for gaming
I couldn't be happier with a and the
best bit the battery life I've been
playing for 30 minutes the battery
hasn't even moved I'm super super
impressed with it and I'm not just
showing off this time I'm actually gonna
give away five of these to you guys so
just check out the link in description
and you can win one of these as well
I'll start the video I just need to
finish up don't worry about it check out
link in the description hello everybody
got a microphone green screen
what 30pi really sucked up the quality
and I noticed that and I'm gonna leave a
like on this video because of that my
god it's hot in here here we go
interaction with people and way to
interact with people this is definitely
the most normal way you can do that the
[ __ ] is this I spent all that time
loading for this dude oh my god alright
what the hell where are you going
hey man hey hey hey hey you hey hey hey
hello hey hey hey do excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me excuse me hello
hello hello you are dragon ball them hey
look it's me why is being social so
difficult it's hard enough in real life
how I interact with people online
how tell me I want to be social
I want to communicate I'm going to make
friends but here I am alone it's fast
ah holy [ __ ] I can be guts hell hell
this would be a lot more fun if I had
friends wait I can be a Yoshi car great
are you [ __ ] kidding me hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey what's up
can you guys hear me can you see me take
this boom submarine no it's a Yoshi
submarine
guys gonna submarine a robot yes it can
I don't think they can hear me still how
long can you hear me hello hello hello
can you hear me
Hey hey buddy hey buddy can you hear me
can you hear me hello hey can you hear
me dan yeah you to me you join up no the
Robins where do I become poopy butthole
hey come on yes oh I can't go close it
no no no no solid ass no do it no
where's the Szechuan sauce okay
it's you where's the Szechuan sauce
I'm pickle beep [ __ ] salad ass yeah
what up fam how you doing
not to bait me
jesus [ __ ] christ what is that
let me come on let me let me touch it
listen listen fatty
give me your fattest dab and I will
think about it what did you I called you
a fat son of a [ __ ] huh would you want
do about it
okay everyone turn around oh don't you
to see this hey hey hey I have a wife
wait stop leave me alone all the poopie
balls went to the different world man
which world take me back please my life
depends on when I write pewdiepie bro
what I'm pooping bottle what are you
talking about I'm the real poopy bottle
that's right keep trying to tell you
everyone three would do the little dance
the pokeball hold aims yes right now
oh [ __ ] is the room one that's right
that's right I've been trying to tell
you case I know everyone else has been
freaking me there's not enough can do
this that's fine that's right what is
the benefit of this cult thank you right
house care hell yeah I'm and your IQ
increases by tenfold
get the [ __ ] tank
where do you go where to go that same
thing down
hey penguin penguin if you join will
give you massage Oh what all right let
me just let me just do yeah we'll give
you yeah look he'll give you a little
massage look I'll give you a massage
oh yeah you like that
and I want this is a democracy
this is election night in America listen
there will be free health care for
everyone at all now shut up shut up I
will offer the same health care but get
this
it's better yeah that's nice yeah yeah I
know is it better explain to me how it's
better free tacos every Friday I will do
that hardest damn I have ever done to
prove to me that this man is not worthy
you're salty of a 5 system otherwise he
comes
are you ready